well you still have time for more
holiday shopping fashion expert john
paul riccio shows us some
perfect stocking stuffers still looking
for the perfect stocking stuffer don't
worry we've got you covered let's
welcome fashion expert john paul riccio
for more in his winter wonderland
what do you have for us i'm so excited
so it's all about
last minute gifts for whomever you love
in your life we're going to start off
with chanel number five chanel number
five
is a staple in female fragrances around
the world it's at its hundredth
anniversary
and it is a number one fragrance for
women and they just love it i
highly recommend it to anyone including
yourself you are speaking my language
that would love to smell luxurious you
know it's fabulous
we've got the amazing charlotte tilbury
as
everyone knows charlotte tilbury she has
an array of amazing products
that are suited for every type of woman
and man they have
amazing incredible uh eye shadow
palettes
and we've got some creams and these
beautiful beautiful
lustrous um lip balms and this is
perfect for christmas morning you want
to
give yourself a little touch up and a
little bit of glam or if you're doing a
zoom holiday call you know
this is for you i feel like what about
for tech for tech
we're looking at the iphone 12 the
iphone 12 mini which is right here i'll
pick it up
it's a perfect stocking stuffer and also
the earbuds that i'm using right now are
amazing for
a stocking stuffer and any tech would
just
love love love to have this i know that
could be for women and men but what do
you have specifically for the males
so for men there's the aqua bomb belief
sleep mask as well as the echo beautiful
slippers they're amazing and also rocky
we've got these incredible scents from
hugo boss
this is called descent and this one is
hugo reverse
i swear any man in your life you will
keep them
coming and coming because they will love
to wear these scents
after the hugo we've got an incredible
array of hamilton watches
which are tom cruise uh major major
movie stars wear these watches i'm
wearing them right now
and i love these and this is the last
thing i want to mention is the
woodpecker
jackets these will keep you warm
wherever you are in the world they're
totally unisex yeah
men women and children can wear these
thank you so much john paul where can
people get more information and follow
you for tips
so you can follow me at john paul
riccio's my instagram and
every single one of these products will
be listed on your website
great